WHICH WAS FILLED WITH RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
HERE NOW SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY OF
MISSOURI.
I JUST THINK HILLARY CLINTON
DOESN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT SHE IS
DOING.
SHE POINTS TO VANITY FAIR?
TO SHOW HOW TO COVER SOMETHING?
THEY COVERED UP THE EPSTEIN
DEAL.
SENATOR HAWLEY, DO YOU THINK SHE
IS AWARE OF THAT.
>> WHAT I THINK IS HAPPENING NOW
THERE IS WAS COLLUSION AFTER ALL
IN THE 2016 CAMPAIGN.
THE COLLUSION WAS BETWEEN
HILLARY CLINTON AND SOME TECH
EXECUTIVES WHO DID, IN FACT, SPY
ON DONALD TRUMP WHO DID, ACCESS
HIS EMAIL SERVERS.
AND WORSE THAN THAT, WHO WENT
ON, ACCORDING TO SPECIAL
COUNSEL, WENT ON TO TRY AND
INFILTRATE THAT IS SPY ON THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
I MEAN, THIS IS SOME CRAZY,
CRAZY STUFF THAT HILLARY HAS
BEEN INVOLVED IN AND NOW IT
TURNS OUT THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
WAS REALLY JUST A CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISE WHICH IS WHAT WE HAVE
KNOWN ALL ALONG.
SOMEBODY SHOULD GO TO JAIL FOR
THIS AND I HOPE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL IS PRETTY SOON GOING TO
BE TALKING TO HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Jesse: CAN YOU DO ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS?
YOU MUST HAVE SOME SORT OF
SUBPOENA POWER.
YOU ARE A POWERFUL SENATOR.
YOU ARE ON A BUNCH OF REALLY
IMPORTANT COMMITTEES, SENATOR.
THERE MUST BE SOMETHING YOU CAN
DO.
AT LEAST KICK UP SOME DUST WITH
THESE PEOPLE.
>> I THINK I JUST DISCOVERED A
GOOD USE FOR THAT JANUARY 6TH
COMMITTEE OVER THERE IN THE
HOUSE.
ONCE REPUBLICANS TAKE BACK THE
HOUSE IN NOVEMBER IF THAT
COMMITTEE WANTS TO LOOK TO
INTERFERENCE IN PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS START THERE THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION THAT
HILLARY CLINTON TRIED TO STEAL
BY COLLUDING WITH BIG TECH, BY
SPYING ON HER OPPONENT AND, YES,
BY LYING TO THE FBI AND THEN
LYING TO FEDERAL COURTS.
THAT LOOKS LIKE SOMETHING THAT'S
WORTHY OF INVESTIGATION TO ME.
>> Jesse: THEY WANT TO
INVESTIGATE YOU FOR A MUG THAT
YOU ARE SELLING ON A WEBSITE I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE BIG DEAL IS
A MUG.
THIS A SCANDAL IN D.C.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ISSUE A
STATEMENT, SENATOR?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, IT'S SUCH AN OUTRAGE
THEY SAY THAT I AM FEARLESSLY
AND UNREPENTEDLY REPRESENTING MY
STATE.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE SAID, JESSE,
THEY SAID THAT I WOULD -- THAT I
WAS SUPPORTING A RIOT BACK ON
JANUARY OF OF 6TH.
THEY SAID I WAS STIRRING UP
INSURRECTION.
ALL LIES WHAT I HAVE BEEN DOING
AND WHAT I WILL CONTINUE TO DO
IS TO REPRESENT THE VIEWS OF THE
PEOPLE OF MY STATE, STAND UP FOR
ELECTION INTEGRITY AND FAIR
ELECTIONS.
IF YOU WANT TO BUY THE MUG GO TO
JOSH HAWLEY.COM.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN'T DO THIS, YOU
CAN'T PUT THE FIST UP.
YOU CAN'T DO HANDS U